bentornati a Quantum Computing in pratica, sono Olivia Lan e l'episodio di oggi, il terzo, si concentrerà su un
esperimento qaoa su scala di utilità se sei con noi dall'inizio hai visto come abbiamo esplorato
l'hardware IBM Quantum, il framework dei pattern di Qiskit e le tecniche più avanzate di mitigazione degli errori che
ricercatori e sviluppatori usano per scalare i Quantum circuit ci è sembrato davvero importante darti tutto questo
contesto e mostrarti la direzione che stavamo prendendo ma ora non c'è più motivo di aspettare oltre per vedere tutte queste informazioni in
azione ora alcune cose da tenere a mente prima di iniziare tutto seguirà il framework dei pattern di Qiskit
quindi percorreremo questi passaggi in ordine il numero uno è la mappatura del problema due l'ottimizzazione del circuit tre
l'esecuzione con i Primitives e quattro la post-elaborazione o analisi dei risultati inizieremo con un esempio abbastanza piccolo
così puoi familiarizzare al meglio con questi passaggi e il loro scopo poi discuteremo un esempio molto simile ma molto
più grande per mostrarti come si scala il problema fino al livello dei 100 qubit ti darò tutti gli
strumenti per consentirti di andare avanti dopo questa lezione e di eseguire quel problema in autonomia infine questo non sarà
una guida al codice passo per passo per quanto ci proviamo man mano che avanziamo il codice invecchia e diventa obsoleto quindi se finisci per
guardare questo video un anno dopo il lancio non voglio che tu ti blocchi sulla sintassi che potrebbe cambiare leggermente nel tempo invece questa sarà una
discussione dettagliata della logica e dell'enunciato del problema tuttavia c'è un tutorial con notebook allegato a questo
video nella descrizione qui sotto seguire il codice o consultarlo dopo che hai
guardato questa lezione ed eseguirlo tu stesso ti darà la migliore esperienza di apprendimento possibile quindi come rapido promemoria non
tutti i problemi computazionali sono adatti al Quantum Computing i problemi semplici e i calcoli elementari non hanno bisogno di
sfruttare questa tecnologia perché i computer classici sono già perfettamente adatti a risolverli a partire dal 2024 i
tre domini in cui siamo più ottimisti da esplorare sono questi: simulare la natura, elaborare dati con struttura complessa
e infine l'ottimizzazione i problemi di ottimizzazione sono tra i più difficili dal punto di vista computazionale
da risolvere in modo efficiente in un problema di ottimizzazione si cerca il valore più grande o più piccolo possibile
per una determinata funzione di costo tuttavia per molti problemi di interesse trovare questo estremo diventa esponenzialmente più
difficile con l'aumentare della dimensione del problema ecco perché diventa così difficile da calcolare per fare un esempio puoi immaginare quanto sia
difficile calcolare i percorsi di volo ottimali o le rotte di consegna in tutto il paese in questa lezione esploreremo
un particolare problema di ottimizzazione chiamato Max cut che risolveremo usando un
algoritmo quantistico chiamato quantum approximation optimization algorithm o qaoa quindi cos'è il problema del max cut un
problema di taglio massimo è un tipo di problema di ottimizzazione combinatoria definito su un grafo dove l'obiettivo è
partizionare i vertici del grafo in due sottoinsiemi in modo che il numero di archi tra i due sottoinsiemi sia
massimizzato quindi ad esempio in questo grafo qui ogni nodo è connesso così e il max cut è mostrato da questa linea ondulata
che divide i nodi nel gruppo viola e nel gruppo grigio il modo per farlo attraversando il maggior numero
possibile di archi è tagliare attraverso cinque archi per questo grafo qui poiché il grafo è così piccolo
non è difficile provare alcuni tagli possibili su carta o anche a mente e capire che cinque è il valore migliore possibile
ma immagina se il numero di nodi raddoppiasse e poi triplicasse questo diventa rapidamente impossibile da fare a
mano e dopo un certo numero diventa così complicato che anche i supercomputer faticano a restituire la risposta migliore questo perché
il numero massimo di tagli scala esponenzialmente con il numero di nodi anche se questo può sembrare un po' astratto
ci sono molti problemi del mondo reale che possono essere ricondotti a un problema Max cut come il rilevamento di frodi in finanza il
clustering di grafi la progettazione di reti e il design VLSI nonché l'analisi dei social media quello dei
social media è particolarmente facile da capire supponi di voler trovare un gruppo di individui che abbiano il maggior numero possibile di
connessioni con altri individui su una piattaforma social per identificare power user o persone con
la maggiore influenza in un gruppo le aziende lo fanno piuttosto spesso un ultimo punto: il max cut è spesso
una subroutine di un problema più grande quindi potrebbe non definire l'applicazione concreta ma essere usato sotto la scocca è
molto più comune di quanto potresti ingenuamente pensare ora è il momento di iniziare il
primo passo è creare il nostro grafo puoi farlo importando un pacchetto Python chiamato rustworks definisci quanti
nodi stai usando specificando il numero n poi aggiungi i tuoi nodi al grafo G dovrai anche
disegnare i tuoi archi lo faremo a mano qui elencandoli in un array come questo dove mostri l'ultimo
numero che specifica il peso dell'arco o quanto fortemente i due nodi indicati sono connessi qui stiamo usando solo
un peso di uno per tutti ma potresti divertirti a giocare con il peso più avanti e vedere come cambia la soluzione
per capire meglio cosa significa il peso in questo contesto torniamo al nostro esempio dei social media puoi pensare
a questo peso come a quanto una persona possa essere influente per un'altra la tua connessione con il coniuge o un parente
per esempio avrebbe probabilmente un peso più alto rispetto a qualcuno che è solo una conoscenza ora disegna il tuo grafo il
tutorial allegato ti mostrerà la sintassi corretta prima di considerare come
mappare questo problema su un Quantum circuit costruiamo un po' di contesto su come il problema del max cut diventa un problema di ottimizzazione
in primo luogo iniziamo considerando la minimizzazione di una funzione f di x dove l'input x è un
vettore n-dimensionale le cui componenti corrispondono a ciascun nodo del grafo d'ora in poi ci riferiremo a questa funzione
come nostra funzione di costo poi dobbiamo vincolare ciascuna di queste componenti a essere zero o
uno qui intendendo da un lato o dall'altro del taglio possiamo scrivere una funzione come
una coppia di nodi x i e xj che ci dice se il corrispondente arco è nel taglio quindi più la quantità x i + xj
meno x i xj identifica se l'arco è nel taglio se questa quantità è uguale
a uno questo implica che l'arco è nel taglio altrimenti è zero e l'arco non lo è il problema di trovare il
numero massimo di archi nel taglio può quindi essere formulato come la massimizzazione di questa funzione in seguito andremo effettivamente ad
aggiungere un segno meno globale a questa funzione rendendo il nuovo problema equivalente a trovare il minimo di questa funzione
invece e quindi il minimo di f di x in questo caso sarà quando il numero di archi attraversati dal taglio è
massimo scegliamo di inquadrare questo problema come un problema di minimizzazione perché questo ci consente di mapparlo in seguito su un
problema di minimizzazione dell'energia ovvero trovare lo stato fondamentale che è ciò in cui i computer quantistici sono naturalmente davvero bravi
ma ricorda che qui non c'è ancora nulla di legato al Quantum Computing dobbiamo ancora riformulare questo problema in
qualcosa che un computer quantistico possa capire siamo ora pronti ad addentrarci e iniziare il lavoro e il
primo passo è mappare il problema su un Quantum circuit potrebbe non essere ovvio come
passeremo da un grafo come quello che abbiamo appena disegnato a un Quantum circuit ma procediamo con calma ricorda che
cercheremo di risolvere questo problema Max cut usando qaoa nell'algoritmo qaoa vogliamo avere un operatore
l'Hamiltoniano che verrà usato per rappresentare la funzione di costo del nostro problema nonché un
circuit parametrizzato l'ansatz o lo stato di prova che useremo per rappresentare stati quantistici che sono ipotesi ragionate o candidati
alla soluzione del problema possiamo campionare da questi stati candidati e poi valutarli
usando la funzione di costo in questo caso la funzione di costo è f di x ma dobbiamo esprimerla in modo
che risulti nativa per il computer quantistico per questo sfrutteremo una serie di trasformazioni matematiche
per esprimere f di x come una funzione di energia l'Hamiltoniano il primo passo del
processo è esprimere il problema di minimizzazione di f di x come un'ottimizzazione binaria non vincolata quadratica
o QUBO in breve il QUBO è un modo generale per formulare questi problemi di ottimizzazione combinatoria
qui Q è una matrice N per N di numeri reali N corrisponde al numero di
nodi nel nostro grafo cinque per questo esempio e X è lo stesso vettore di variabili binarie della formulazione iniziale
per eseguire efficacemente l'algoritmo qaoa dobbiamo esprimere il nostro problema di ottimizzazione in termini di un
Hamiltoniano che è un operatore matematico che rappresenta l'energia totale di un sistema nello specifico vogliamo
creare un Hamiltoniano della funzione di costo che abbia la proprietà che il suo stato fondamentale o valore minimo dell'energia
corrisponda al minimo della funzione che codifica il numero massimo di tagli sul grafo g una volta che
abbiamo questo Hamiltoniano tutto ciò che dobbiamo fare per risolvere il nostro problema di ottimizzazione è preparare lo stato fondamentale dell'Hamiltoniano sul computer quantistico poi
il campionamento da questo stato con alta probabilità fornirà la soluzione alla minimizzazione di f di X come si scopre
siamo fortunati perché il problema QUBO è strettamente correlato e di fatto computazionalmente equivalente a
uno degli Hamiltoniani più famosi e onnipresenti in fisica l'Hamiltoniano di Ising per scrivere il problema QUBO
come questo Hamiltoniano di Ising tutto ciò che dobbiamo fare è un semplice cambio di variabile per passare da
variabili booleane 0 e 1 a variabili di spin meno uno e uno questo passaggio è
diretto ed è mostrato in modo più dettagliato nell'appendice del notebook allegato per chi è interessato ma alla fine la minimizzazione di questa espressione QUBO
è uguale alla minimizzazione di questa espressione riscrivendo ancora leggermente e
abbiamo la nostra funzione di costo Hamiltoniano dove il minimo dell'espressione rappresenta lo stato fondamentale e Z
diventa l'operatore di Pauli mentre B è un coefficiente scalare reale ora che abbiamo il nostro Hamiltoniano
è semplice riscriverlo in termini di due operatori ZZ di Pauli locali che si convertiranno facilmente in
due gate ZZ nel nostro Quantum circuit fai riferimento al notebook associato per vedere come si fa ma l'output
è dato da questa riga qui nota che nel nostro esempio ci sono
sei oggetti o stringhe di Pauli perché ciascuno rappresenta un arco nel grafo la lunghezza della stringa corrisponde al numero
di nodi quindi I I I ZZ corrisponde a cinque nodi e la stringa sarà composta da
identità in tutte le posizioni tranne che per gli indici dei nodi coinvolti in un arco che avranno termini Z in Qiskit
le stringhe di bit che rappresentano i qubit sono indicizzate al contrario per esempio un arco tra i nodi 0 e 1 verrà codificato come
I I I ZZ con l'Hamiltoniano scritto in termini di Pauli siamo pronti a costruire il nostro
Quantum circuit questo Quantum circuit ci aiuterà a campionare buone soluzioni dal computer quantistico l'algoritmo qaoa
si ispira al teorema adiabatico che afferma che se partiamo dallo stato fondamentale dell'Hamiltoniano dipendente dal tempo
e se l'Hamiltoniano evolve abbastanza lentamente e con abbastanza tempo lo stato finale sarà lo stato fondamentale
dell'Hamiltoniano finale qaoa può essere visto come la versione di Trotter discreta dell'algoritmo quantistico
adiabatico dove ogni passo di Trotter rappresenta un livello che chiameremo P quindi
invece di evolvere da uno stato all'altro in ogni livello P alterneremo avanti e indietro tra la nostra funzione di costo
Hamiltoniano e quello che si chiama Hamiltoniano del mixer di cui sentiremo parlare tra un momento ma il punto che voglio sottolineare
è che qaoa ha il vantaggio di essere più veloce dell'algoritmo quantistico adiabatico ma restituisce soluzioni approssimate
invece che ottimali nel limite in cui il numero di livelli tende a infinito qaoa converge al caso adiabatico
ma ovviamente questo è computazionalmente molto costoso per creare il nostro Quantum circuit
applicheremo operatori alternati qui parametrizzati da gamma e beta che
rappresenteranno la discretizzazione dell'evoluzione temporale quindi ancora una volta le tre parti principali
del circuit qaoa sono uno lo stato di prova iniziale in grigio che è lo stato fondamentale
del mixer a partire dallo stato adiabatico creato applicando un gate Hadamard a ogni qubit due
l'evoluzione della funzione di costo che abbiamo già in viola scuro e tre l'evoluzione sotto il mixer
Hamiltoniano di cui non abbiamo ancora discusso in viola chiaro ora il nostro Hamiltoniano di partenza si chiama
mixer perché il suo stato fondamentale è la sovrapposizione di tutte le possibili stringhe di bit di interesse quindi
imponendo una miscela di tutte le possibili soluzioni all'inizio l'Hamiltoniano del mixer è la semplice somma delle operazioni di Pauli X
su ogni nodo del grafo Qiskit ti consente di usare un diverso operatore mixer personalizzato se lo desideri ma
per questo caso useremo solo quello standard quindi di nuovo puoi vedere che con Qiskit molto lavoro viene
tolto a noi rendendo banale la creazione dell'Hamiltoniano del mixer e dello stato iniziale l'unico lavoro che abbiamo dovuto fare è stato
trovare la funzione di costo ogni iterazione di questi operatori è chiamata un livello questi livelli possono essere visti come
discretizzazioni dell'evoluzione temporale del sistema come descritto in precedenza il pattern alternato deriva dalla
decomposizione di Trotter e approssima le funzioni esponenziali di matrici non commutanti in generale più livelli o
passi includiamo più ci avvicineremo all'evoluzione temporale continua quindi in teoria più accurato sarà il risultato
ma per questo esempio inizieremo campionando con due livelli ricorda che sia l'Hamiltoniano della funzione di costo che
il mixer sono parametrizzati dobbiamo ancora trovare i valori ottimali per gamma e
beta ora so che erano molte informazioni e se vedi questo tipo di matematica per la prima volta può essere difficile per fortuna uno degli aspetti fantastici
di Qiskit è che molto di ciò che abbiamo appena visto può essere fatto automaticamente senza un grande sforzo da parte dell'utente è bello capire cosa succede
sotto la scocca soprattutto man mano che si scala verso esperimenti più grandi ma non dovrai fare tutto questo lavoro a
mano ogni volta abbiamo ora mappato il nostro problema su un Quantum circuit è stato un po' di lavoro
ma non preoccuparti diventa più facile e più intuitivo più lo si fa ora siamo pronti a passare al passo due
ottimizzare il nostro circuit per l'hardware quindi sebbene il circuit che abbiamo appena creato sembri abbastanza semplice ed è
utile per costruire una comprensione intuitiva ricorda che il chip quantistico non capisce cos'è questo blocco astratto
dobbiamo trasformarlo in una serie di gate a uno e due qubit nativi per l'hardware e quando dico
nativo intendo che verrà rifattorizzato in ciò che può essere eseguito direttamente sui qubit questi circuit si
dice siano scritti nell'instruction set architecture del backend che potresti vedere abbreviato come circuiti ISA
il modulo transpiler dell'SDK di Qiskit offre una serie di passaggi di transpilazione che possono
eseguire un'ampia gamma di trasformazioni del circuit vogliamo assicurarci che il nostro circuit sia ottimizzato per il nostro
scopo ricorda dalla nostra lezione precedente che il processo di transpilazione prevede diversi passaggi: la mappatura dei
qubit nel circuit o delle variabili decisionali sui qubit fisici del dispositivo lo srotolamento delle istruzioni nel
Quantum circuit sulle istruzioni native all'hardware che il backend capisce effettivamente il routing dei
qubit nel circuit che interagiscono direttamente verso i qubit fisici adiacenti uno
all'altro e come sempre maggiori dettagli si trovano sul sito della documentazione
ora arriva un passo emozionante dove sceglieremo su quale backend eseguire il nostro circuit in realtà dobbiamo farlo
prima del passaggio di transpilazione perché il transpiler ottimizza in modo diverso per processori diversi questo è un altro motivo per cui è
importante che Qiskit possa automatizzare così tanta parte di questa fase non vorresti dover ottimizzare il tuo circuit a mano
il che è possibile ma a volte è complicato e molto dispendioso in termini di tempo solo per renderti conto che in realtà vuoi eseguirlo
su un processore diverso con proprietà diverse e poi devi rifare tutto quel lavoro passa il
tuo backend preferito attraverso la funzione del transpiler e non dimenticare di specificare il livello di ottimizzazione questa
volta ho selezionato il livello di ottimizzazione tre che è il più alto e il più esaustivo
e in realtà è tutto per il passo due il mio circuit è stato transpilato automaticamente e l'ho disegnato qui così che
puoi vedere come è stato tradotto in gate a uno e due qubit ora è il momento per il passo tre
eseguire il circuit con i Primitives di Qiskit finora abbiamo transpilato il circuit lasciando i parametri gamma e
beta invariati ma non possiamo effettivamente eseguire il circuit senza specificare il valore di questi parametri nel workflow
qaoa i parametri qaoa ottimali vengono trovati in un ciclo di ottimizzazione iterativo dove eseguiamo una serie di valutazioni del circuit
e usiamo un ottimizzatore classico per trovare i parametri beta e gamma ottimali tuttavia dobbiamo iniziare da
qualche parte quindi ho implementato alcune ipotesi iniziali per Gamma 1 gamma 2 e beta 1 beta 2 di Pi / 2 e Pi
rispettivamente voglio anche che tu noti che useremo un ottimizzatore per trovare soluzioni migliori per gamma e Beta
e poiché sto calcolando solo due livelli per ora è tutto ciò di cui ho bisogno ma se crei un circuit qaoa più accurato
includeresti più livelli e avresti quindi bisogno di un gamma e beta ottimizzati per ogni livello sequenziale
ora prendiamoci solo un minuto per fare una pausa e ricordare le nostre opzioni per i Primitives abbiamo l'estimator e
il sampler quale pensi che useremo per questo tipo di lavoro beh qualunque cosa tu abbia risposto
hai ragione useremo sia l'estimator che il sampler per l'ottimizzazione iniziale
avremo bisogno dell'estimator ma useremo il sampler più avanti per leggere la soluzione finale
siamo quasi pronti a eseguire il nostro algoritmo te lo prometto ma molto rapidamente è importante notare che puoi
inviare il tuo job in vari modi diversi che si chiamano modalità di esecuzione prima abbiamo la job mode una singola
richiesta primitiva dell'estimator o del sampler fatta senza un context manager i circuit e gli input vengono confezionati come primitive
unified blocks (PUB) e inviati come task di esecuzione sul computer
quantistico la batch mode è un gestore multi-job per eseguire in modo efficiente un esperimento composto da un insieme
di job indipendenti usa la batch mode per inviare più job primitivi simultaneamente la session mode è una finestra dedicata
per eseguire un workload multi-job questo consente agli utenti premium di sperimentare con algoritmi variazionali in modo più
prevedibile e persino di eseguire più esperimenti simultaneamente sfruttando il parallelismo dello
stack usa le sessioni per workflow iterativi ed esperimenti che richiedono accesso dedicato per un esperimento qaoa una
sessione sarebbe una buona scelta da seguire se ne hai accesso poiché dovrai provare più circuit per diversi valori di beta
e gamma bene ora torniamo al nostro problema di ottimizzazione abbiamo già
definito l'Hamiltoniano della funzione di costo HC e il workflow completo è questo l'algoritmo
qaoa inizia inizializzando i qubit nello stato di sovrapposizione e poi applica l'ansatz con P livelli
inizializza i parametri gamma e beta e poi esegue il circuit usando il primitive estimator una volta calcolati
i valori di aspettazione useremo poi un ottimizzatore SciPy chiamato COBYLA COBYLA
ottimizza la funzione di costo in modo classico all'esterno della QPU una volta aggiornati quei valori di gamma e beta
ripetiamo lo faremo fino a quando il valore della funzione di costo complessiva sarà convergato e avrà raggiunto il valore più basso
poi selezioneremo i valori di gamma e beta che corrispondono a questo valore di costo basso ed eseguiremo il circuit un'ultima
volta ora usando il sampler questo è il risultato di me che eseguo l'ottimizzatore COBYLA con le mie ipotesi iniziali qui puoi vedere
che il valore della funzione di costo nelle iterazioni eseguite parte un po' instabile e va su e giù ma
poi si stabilizza su un valore basso useremo questi ultimi valori di gamma e beta che corrispondono al costo minimo
per eseguire il circuit un'ultima volta e campionare la stringa di bit che ci darà il max
cut ora usando i nostri valori ottimizzati per i gamma e i beta eseguiremo il circuit un'ultima volta per trovare la migliore
possibile stringa di bit usando il sampler ho elencato i valori specifici che sto usando qui ma ricorda quando ci provi
tu stesso o anche solo quando riesegui lo stesso notebook del tutorial questi valori potrebbero cambiare leggermente ora eseguiremo
il nostro circuit ottimizzato con questi valori e troveremo la nostra soluzione candidata al nostro problema Max cut se stavi usando
le sessioni ciò non è più necessario poiché stiamo eseguendo solo un ultimo job ora finalmente esamineremo la
fase di post-elaborazione e troveremo la nostra soluzione finale prima tracciamo tutte le
possibili combinazioni di nodi che abbiamo convertito in stringhe di bit come istogramma puoi vedere subito che
quando l'ho eseguito ho trovato quattro soluzioni e ho evidenziato in viola quelle più probabili di qualsiasi altra soluzione
la stringa di bit più alta e quindi più probabile è 0 1 01 nota che l'ordine dei qubit
è invertito nel grafico guardando la soluzione più probabile notiamo che i nodi 0 e tre sono raggruppati insieme
e analogamente i nodi 1 2 e quattro possiamo infine tracciare la stringa di bit più probabile
di nuovo come un grafo e ricorda che la stringa di bit corrisponde semplicemente ai numeri dei nodi e se sono inclusi
contrassegnati con un uno o non inclusi contrassegnati con uno zero nel nostro raggruppamento quando disegniamo il taglio ora possiamo vedere con i nostri occhi la
linea approssimativa per il taglio migliore che rappresenta semplicemente il raggruppamento ideale di tutti e cinque i nodi che ho disegnato qui uno
cosa su cui voglio soffermarmi è il fatto che la soluzione corretta non è unica
a causa della simmetria di questo grafo ci sono più soluzioni corrette invece di avere i nodi 0 e tre
all'interno del taglio potremmo avere i nodi 2 e quattro inclusi e puoi vedere che tutto ciò che ho dovuto fare è stato ruotare il mio taglio per
includere questi nuovi punti questa soluzione di cinque rimane la stessa
diamo un'altra occhiata all'istogramma e alle quattro soluzioni più probabili per un momento le ultime due soluzioni sono quelle che
abbiamo appena tracciato e sono entrambe ugualmente corrette ma non è tutto potremmo anche invertire i colori per tutte
le soluzioni corrette e questa volta pensiamo semplicemente ai nodi come essere dentro rispetto a fuori dal taglio nella
diapositiva precedente abbiamo identificato due soluzioni corrette uniche ma in realtà ci sono altre due soluzioni una corrispondente al
contrario di ciascuna di queste vedi come qui dove ho disegnato le due soluzioni rimanenti ho semplicemente invertito i
colori ora l'unico problema è che l'algoritmo in realtà non ha trovato o identificato questa quarta soluzione come
una delle prime quattro risposte più probabili era la quinta la quarta soluzione che l'algoritmo ha identificato
è in realtà errata e se la disegnassi vedresti che quella soluzione ha solo quattro tagli e poiché le altre
ne hanno cinque e quattro è chiaramente inferiore a cinque questa è ovviamente sbagliata il punto qui
è che questo è un algoritmo approssimativo non è infallibile e non è corretto al 100% delle volte devi
impiegare parte della tua conoscenza e comprensione per verificare le soluzioni vale la pena evidenziare che
questo errore può derivare da diversi posti potrebbe essere la natura approssimativa dell'algoritmo stesso e il piccolo
numero di livelli che ho scelto di impiegare potrebbe essere un errore di campionamento finito e questo potrebbe essere ridotto se aumento il
numero di shot nel mio esperimento oppure potrebbe essere un errore di readout poiché la quarta soluzione reale differisce solo di un
bit il motivo per cui evidenzio tutte queste possibilità è perché è questo che ci vuole per diventare pienamente un
praticante del Quantum Computing devi capire le prestazioni dell'hardware e come questo può contribuire a
certi tipi di errori e come correggerli tuttavia non dimentichiamo che
c'erano 32 possibili soluzioni come stringhe di bit e che le quattro soluzioni reali erano incluse nelle prime cinque
migliori candidate e ho usato solo due livelli per trovarlo in generale se voglio aumentare le mie possibilità di trovare il
migliore max cut ogni volta aumenterei la profondità dei livelli ci sono alcune sottigliezze in questo ma è per un episodio successivo
ora ti lascerò provare tu stesso ma questa volta userai 100
qubit quindi se iniziamo disegnando il nostro grafo di 100 qubit puoi vedere che non è più semplice o anche possibile
identificare a occhio dove si trova il max cut ci sono semplicemente troppe possibilità per poterle individuare a mano ma
risolvere questo problema usando qaoa è ancora del tutto fattibile e puoi seguire lo stesso workflow che abbiamo usato per 5
qubit sto per lasciarti andare da solo e affidarti questo esperimento ma prima di farlo
facciamo un riepilogo ricorda che i sei passi di qualsiasi job qaoa sono i seguenti uno definire
un Hamiltoniano di costo tale che il suo stato fondamentale codifichi la soluzione al problema di ottimizzazione due definire un
Hamiltoniano del mixer tre costruire gli operatori corrispondenti agli Hamiltoniani
esponenziali quattro costruire il circuit consisterà nello stato fondamentale iniziale del mixer e livelli
alternati ripetuti della funzione di costo e dell'evoluzione sotto l'Hamiltoniano del mixer cinque preparare uno stato iniziale e
usare tecniche di calcolo classico per ottimizzare i parametri sei eseguire il circuit misurare le stringhe di bit in output
cercando la soluzione più probabile ora alcune cose da notare
ho usato il livello di ottimizzazione tre per il mio esempio a 5 qubit ma forse non era necessario e la risposta giusta potrebbe
essere restituita la maggior parte delle volte anche a un livello di ottimizzazione inferiore perché la profondità del circuit era abbastanza bassa per il caso a 5
qubit ma per i 100 qubit e una grande profondità del circuit quasi certamente avrai bisogno del livello più alto di
ottimizzazione per trovare la risposta giusta tieni anche presente che una delle parti più impegnative di un tipico workflow su scala
di utilità è la fase di mappatura e trovare un grafo che corrisponda bene alla topologia heavy hex di IBM se stai svolgendo
questo lavoro da zero è indubbiamente lì che dedicheresti la maggior parte del tuo tempo per ora questa parte è stata
fatta per te perché non è il punto principale di questo esercizio ma tieni a mente che è qualcosa che
richiede pratica ed eseguire un job su larga scala non è sempre così semplice approfondiremo questo
ulteriormente nell'episodio 4 il tuo circuit finale sarà ovviamente molto più caotico del circuit che ha girato su 5 qubit
ma d'altra parte mi sembra che guardare questo circuit e vedere quanti gate ha e sapere che
hai la capacità di eseguirlo effettivamente su processori quantistici reali sia piuttosto
impressionante e questa era la mia soluzione finale puoi vedere che l'algoritmo è certamente in grado di raggruppare questi
nodi in due gruppi identificando presumibilmente il miglior max cut che li divide passare dai due insiemi
alla linea del max cut stesso è banale ovunque il colore cambia lungo le linee che collegano i nodi indica
dove dovrebbe essere tracciata la linea del max cut quando l'ho eseguito il valore del max cut che sono riuscito a ottenere è
84 quindi provaci tu stesso e fammi sapere nei commenti se ottieni qualcosa di simile prova tre livelli magari quattro prova
a cambiare i pesi tra i nodi e vedi come cambia il risultato ci sono molti esperimenti interessanti
che possiamo eseguire con qaoa ora ricorda che non è garantito che abbia appena trovato la migliore soluzione possibile
sappiamo che è una buona soluzione ma per divertimento ti sfido a battermi vedi se riesci a ottenere qualcosa
di meglio di 84 in conclusione qaoa è un algoritmo molto dinamico
e ci sono molte euristiche e ancora molto da esplorare lascia molto spazio per imparare cose nuove
sul campo dell'ottimizzazione in generale c'è stato molto lavoro recente nello spazio dell'ottimizzazione come
dimostrato da tutti gli articoli di archivio che sono stati recentemente pubblicati online su qaoa o sull'ottimizzazione e ciò che è
davvero interessante è che finalmente non tutti questi articoli sono articoli di teoria i teorici hanno lavorato e studiato
qaoa per anni ma ora gli sperimentalisti si stanno coinvolgendo perché finalmente abbiamo l'hardware
come i processori IBM che sono in grado di eseguire molti di questi esperimenti stiamo passando dallo spazio immaginativo
al mondo reale e questo è molto emozionante sì c'è ancora molto lavoro da fare e ci sono ancora
molti errori su cui dobbiamo capire come gestire ma stiamo avanzando rapidamente e tu che guardi questo
video se sei arrivato fin qui sei capace di eseguire questi esperimenti tu stesso per favore vai a provare a eseguire il tuo
esperimento da 100 qubit e facci sapere come è andata segui il tutorial e sarai in buone mani e se hai
domande o ti blocchi non preoccuparti tutti noi ci siamo sentiti così o abbiamo avuto le stesse domande quando abbiamo iniziato
a imparare questo fai del tuo meglio facci sapere quali domande incontri e ci vediamo la prossima volta
[Musica]